c'est la crise invisible oubliée celle
de la vie sur terre du géant au tout
petit
sur les 8 millions d'espèces vivantes
connues un million sont menacés
d'extinction c'est un tiers des espèces
de coraux de mammifères marins de
conifères ses 40% des espèces
d'amphibiens 60% des cicadales une des
formes les plus primitives de plantes le
taux d'extinction et des dizaines voire
des centaines de fois plus élevées que
la moyenne des 10 derniers millions
d'années ce sont les conclusions de ce
rapport le travail d'un groupe
intergouvernemental de centaines
d'experts les baisses l'équivalent du
GIEC mais pour la biodiversité
c'est le portrait le plus complet que
nous ayons de la perte de biodiversité
il a été approuvé et signé par des
représentants de 132 pays
les causes de cet effondrement d'abord
et avant tout la perte d'habitat
75% de la surface terrestre est altérée
de manière significative comme 66 % des
océans
85% de la surface des eaux humides ont
disparu puis il y a l'exploitation non
durable comme les pêches la foresterie
les changements climatiques la pollution
les espèces envahissantes
pourtant cette diversité de la vie est
essentielle aux humains pour réguler le
climat pour purifier les os
75% des cultures alimentaires mondiales
reposent sur la pollinisation animale
70% des médicaments contre le cancer
proviennent de la nature ou en sont
inspirés en 1992 au Sommet de la Terre
de Rio de Janeiro les dirigeants ont
reconnu à l'unisson le sérieux de la
crise climatique mais aussi celui de la
perte de biodiversité un enjeu qu'il
reconnaisse être de même important
il s'engage à corriger le tir et signe
la convention pour la diversité
biologique pour conserver la diversité
biologique et encourager les mesures
pour un avenir durable
depuis l'enjeu des changements
climatiques a fait son chemin dans les
médias le public jusque dans les agendas
politiques des cibles claires ont été
fixées mais ce n'est pas le cas pour la
biodiversité les accords ont été signés
pour s'attaquer à cet effondrement du
vivant celui d'Haïti un plan pour 2020
fixait 20 objectifs aucun n'a été
atteint la biodiversité continue de
chuter sans frein
se décembre les pays se rencontrent à
Montréal lors de la COP 15 pour se doter
d'un plan pour la prochaine décennie on
souhaite l'équivalent de l'accord de
Paris mais pour la biodiversité l'espoir
et que 2022 marque un point tournant
historique pour la vie sur Terre